what's going on everybody welcome to a
part 3 of the jingo web development
series I'm your host centex and let's
get into it today what we're gonna be
talking about is the admin page of Jango
as well as a an opportunity for me to
show off just how easily we could
incorporate other people's apps for all
kinds of things and we'll just show a
really quick example by the end of this
one so let's get into it so the first
thing we're gonna do is to use admin we
need a super user we don't have one so
the first thing that we're gonna do is
create one so I'm gonna open up command
prompt here and I'm gonna say Python
manage PI create super user and then
here what we're gonna do is pick a user
name the default would be like your
computer's name I'm using a paper space
virtual machine here says why is this
paper space but I'm gonna call mine
syntax email address you can put one or
not it doesn't really matter if you do
have one later on down the line like
right now we're running Jango with debug
equals true so we get and see the
debugging messages so it's no big deal
later when you push your website to
production Jango has a sort of reporting
functionality because you won't be
running with debug equals true and you
can incorporate and allow Jango to
actually email you when certain errors
are hit so there could be a reason you
want to add an email address here but
just like everything else with Jango if
you decide not to do it now like that
you can always come back and revisit
this later you can just edit the
username and add the email address no
big deal password I always use
programming as my password Dilla or
python is amazing 1 2 3 ok so we've got
a user created and we're ready to
rhumble side note of course don't make
your passwords super simple for your
admin account otherwise someone could
log into your admin and then what I'm
about to show you with admin should tell
you why you wouldn't like that to occur
ok so what we want to do now that we've
got this admin user we actually could
run this
server and check things out so actually
I'm gonna go Python managed PI run
server because I don't have another one
running right now and let's go ahead and
head to our website slash admin boom we
got a login and it's way zoomed in okay
sent Dex and programming is awesome one
two three okay and what we get here is
the Django admin page here we can see a
couple of things we've got groups and
users we could go ahead and click on
users boom
there's your Centex user that you just
created we could click on that user boom
we've got the username password which is
this hashed out password basically but
then here we've got some personal
information that we could change the
reason why this is all here is because
the admin user or the super user is just
a version of a user and the user the
Django user model has fields for name
and email address and all that so
anyways that's why that's already there
now I know you must be wondering well
what about our model because we just
made a model in the last tutorial
where's that at well you have to
register your models so you go to the
Django registration you cut out a little
piece of the cardboard that your Django
package came in to correct myself oh
okay so what we got to do is go into
Maine and we just go into the admin here
and in fact I told myself I was gonna
keep using this one so we go here and
register your models here so all we have
to do is actually import the tutorial
models so from models import tutorial
don't forget the relative period there
and then all we need to do is admin dot
site dot regice regice and we could do
tutorial like that tutorial hopefully I
spelled that right let's find out let's
refresh boom tutorials interestingly
enough this has an S appended to it even
though the you know tutorial is singular
I forget what it is
there there is a method you can override
eventually we will probably hit it but
it because it's kind of annoying so a
turn like series what it's going to do
this just adds an S to it it doesn't
have any handling for if the thing ends
and s maybe do like es or or just a a an
apostrophe ER so it doesn't it's really
stupid it just adds an S so so anyway
later what we can fix that but that's
where the S is coming from it's
literally taking the model name plus s
so yeah but later on down the line when
you're like trying to go back and figure
out where is it getting the name from
that's what's going on
so anyway been there done that ok so
that's how we could register it super
simple and if we click on tutorials boom
we can already see the tutorial that we
actually made and all the fields are
here and notice how like you the date
published has this thing like today and
now and you could click on a calendar
and pick all these things are done for
us and like for example here this is car
filled and it's just like a short field
and here you've got this big field here
because this is a text field and I just
think that's so cool if anybody's ever
had to make an admin like control panel
and ACP and needed to do all of this
stuff that's all our work and even
though this is like super basic I mean a
lot of stuff went into this and that's
pretty awesome
so ok so we've got that done now the
next thing I want to talk about is how
we can kind of customize this slightly
later on it's it could get even more
crazy than what we're about to do but
just to show you that you can do this
what we'll do is rather than just
registering the model so for example
your models could have like 100
attributes but you might only want to
edit a handful of them like some of them
might be defaults like what was the
temperature or something like that that
you would never edit ok so you might not
want all the fields you also might want
to like organize the fields in different
ways or in different orders and so on so
or set for example a default so right
now if I go to this tutorial and either
add tutorial here or even back here you
could say add so we could add another
tutorial here
let's just add a quick print tutorial
tutorial actually I'm gonna save this
for now I don't want to add add one
right now
I'll save that for later we will add
some more but I'm gonna wait until after
the amazing app changes so the first
thing that we should do is how can we
customize like the order and like the
setup of tutorial here so what we're
gonna do is we could say here class and
we're just gonna say tutorial admin and
this it will inherit from admin dot
model admin so it's just it basically
when we register all we're gonna do is
actually register tutorial with tutorial
admin here and this was just assumed
before now we're just overriding it
basically and these are the parameters
by which we are going to override it
we're gonna say hey we want the
following fields and you'll just pass a
list here so for example each field
would be an attribute so tutorial title
was one of them and let's just add the
thickest it was three then we had
tutorial content and then we had
tutorial published should be right let's
refresh for real quick make sure it's
all looking hunky-dory show or enough
okay
but tutorial publish maybe we want that
like up above right so what we could do
is come into here and just change the
order cut paste that was ugly oh so so
ugly
who almost got got by that
not today Python not today okay so now
we got the different order here another
thing that we could do is you can
separate them by fields just again if
you had like a hundred you might want to
like cluster them together or something
so this we don't really have enough to
show that truly but anyway I'll just
show it real basically okay field sets
okay
so now we can actually separate them
into sets so for example we could say
title date in this set is fields and
then in here we'll put a tutorial title
and tutorial published then we'll have
another set which will be called content
and then in here we can pass fields and
then tutorial content and I can get rid
of that hopefully I'll fluid an error
let's see what happens boom awesome Wow
usually I would make a typo by then so
as you can see we got these like little
dividers basically for the date data
types okay
pretty cool pretty cool the next thing
is that we could do is for example if I
go to I don't want to delete let's go to
tutorials add a tutorial you can see
here like the date is empty one of the
things that I wouldn't mind doing really
quickly is changing our model here let's
go models
pi and here you see where we have
tutorial published equals model that
date time field then we call it date
published one of the parameters that we
can put into one of these is a default
so I would like to default to be a date
time now so what we can say is from date
time import date time and then date time
dot now boom save that and that would be
a change to our model so I don't think
we're gonna get away with let's see what
happens I'm trying to decide if that
would require I don't imagine that's
gonna require a migration I don't know
that's a good question actually let's
see what happens
nope didn't require a migration nice so
now when you hit new tutorial boom
that's already in there so why that
didn't require migration I guess you
would have to it must be Django is
running like Python to set those
defaults would be my guess because this
is never it's not an SQL default right
it's because this book as we when we hit
new right here this doesn't create any
SQL yet nothing is you know inserted SQL
wise until we probably hit save so
that's probably why we didn't need it
migrate but we also could have found out
like if you're if you're uncertain
you're it's never gonna be a big deal if
you if you get lost how many things are
going to minimize if you just quickly do
a Python managed up I make migrations if
you just check well I would actually
alter so it does want to alter it
fascinating but it actually made the
change
interesting already forgot uh let's just
I guess we could go ahead and Python
mashup I migrate fine oh okay hey that's
interesting even though that was already
hint it didn't seem like a migrate it
was required anyway okay very very
interesting so the big thing now is when
I come into here like imagine actually
trying to write tutorials in here now
maybe not everybody here is written a
tutorial but this is like plain text
which would be really really painful in
very tedious also you guys probably
don't want to read Python code written
strict straight into there that would
probably not be pleasant so instead what
we want is some sort of like editor and
they make editors called like what you
see is what you get types of editors now
I just did a quick search for some
editors for Jengo and I found that
there's one called tiny MCE for - light
so all we need to do to grab that and
that's like it's a jangle app that we
can just add to our app so all we need
to do first is install it so I'm gonna
come over I'm guessing this is nope
okay so I'm gonna come over here and
real quick
I already forget if pip corresponds to
three seven or not yes so I'm gonna go
pip install Django - tiny MCE for -
light what oh s--- it was a slash pip
somehow okay let's just check pip okay
okay so if you want to follow along you
can it's pretty lightweight package if
you don't want to follow along just
watch that's totally fine too but
basically my goal here is to just show
you how quickly and easily you can add
someone else's app so anyways pip
install Django this is basically it's
just something that's gonna override
certain model pipes so what we're going
to override here is the
like this text field that we've got and
we're gonna turn that instead into like
an editor so okay so we've installed
Django tiny MCE for light great so we
have that now what we need to do is add
this to our installed apps because we
want to call upon it we want to be able
to point URLs towards it and so on so
first thing we're going to do is stop
trying to edit in here go to our little
sublime here and we're gonna go into my
site and settings dot pie come down to
installed apps and I'm just gonna add it
down here and I'm going to say tiny MCE
is the name of the app so the next thing
I'm going to do and by the way if you
are curious about it
I do have put a link to the text-based
version in the description and you're
definitely gonna want to start heading
that way really quickly because I'm
gonna make this huge copy and paste that
there's no way I'm gonna write out on a
video boom there's the copy and paste so
these are the configuration settings for
our tiny MCE widget basically it's all
the things that we want included here
one of the things that I want to like be
able to click on buttons and all that
kind of stuff so anyways that's there
cool so there's that and in the so if
you go to a text-based version of the
tutorial you can just copy and paste
that snippet also I link to all of the
config possible configurations so if you
wanted to kind of change this around
this is just one of the more default
ones the next thing we would need to do
is be able to point our app to tiny MCE
because our widgets are gonna call upon
tiny MCE to work so we're gonna come
down here and we're gonna say path and
we're going to allow the path of tiny
MCE and basically that's going to work
with include tiny MCE dot URLs this
needs to be in quotes cool at the comma
so I don't forget later on alright so
now what we want to do is hopefully save
that let me make sure we're not hitting
errors
yet good it looks like everything is
working up to this point now we want to
do is head over to our admins so in main
admin dot PI now we want to do is first
we need to make the import and what we
want to say is from tiny MCE widgets
we're going to import the tiny MCE
widget also from Django dot DV we're
gonna import models because we're
actually going to just modify the model
here for admin purposes so we wouldn't
want we don't necessarily want every
text field to be an editor right across
our entire website we just want the this
one we just want one to be so what we're
gonna say here is basically under our
field sets we're also going to make a
quick change and we're gonna say form
field underscore overrides equals and
then we're gonna say models dot text
field that's actually a title cased text
field and that will be a widget widget
and that's tiny MCE oh my goodness there
we go okay so that will override that
that specific text field just for
tutorial admin for us we could do the
something very similar in our models and
all that kind of stuff there's there's
other ways and like so our for our views
to display to like a regular user like
right here we're making all these
changes to admin dot pi which is kind of
like its own separate entity although
some people have I've seen people use
admin and they like extend the admin to
actually be their main website it's kind
of not suggested that you do that but
you you guys suppose you could but I'm
just letting you know this is not the
only use case for tiny MCE or any app
for that matter or any widget that you
want to grab that happens to be an app
and and so on anyway
save that come over here let's make a
refresh darn it I can't get through a
tutorial without something like that
[Music]
let's see what did I do wrong
this probably means this needs to be I
wonder did I get sometimes that
autocorrect smacks me in the face we're
not really autocorrect but the
suggestion I just pretty confident I
didn't make that mistake thanks anyway
like sometimes it suggests then I hit
enter to like make a new line or
whatever and yeah yeah alright anyway
long story short boom we have an editor
now awesome great wonderful okay now so
like for example we could say like print
tutorial okay and then we come down here
and you know you could write stuff
here's how to print things things and
then like you can even enter like a code
snippet so we'll just do this and we'll
define print stuff and then we can pick
a language will go with Python print and
then we'll underscore here cuz that's
proper the thing and grant the thing
also will return the thing because why
wouldn't we brand stuff awesome so then
we've entered a little snippet boom save
that boom now we've got two tutorials
holy moly
[Music]
okay anyway alright so we've got these
tutorials and now we want to be able to
display them and stuff and we definitely
don't want our homepage looking like
that anymore so now we're gonna start
moving into is like views and templates
and stuff like that and getting our
website to look a little better and then
we'll get very briefly I promise into
some design and then back to other
janko's stuff so that's it for now quick
shout out to my most recent channel
members we've got KB jagdish Sean
Ajay Kumar and robo-one one seven three
five thank you guys very much for your
support you guys are awesome
that's it for now questions comments
concerns whatever feel free to leave
them below otherwise I will see you guys
in another video